SHAZIA MAKHDUMI: Hi, everyone.
I'm Shazia Makhdumi from
the Google Play team.
And I'm here to talk
to you about
Google Play for Education.
Imagine a world where every
student and classroom is
connected to the web.
Imagine all the teachers are
able to find any piece of
content they want and
get it to the
right group of students.
At Google, we've started to
make that vision a reality
with Google Play
for Education.
It's a new initiative combining
portable Nexus
tablets with highly
engaging content.
So it includes a dedicated
online store.
And this is different
from Google Play.
And it's just for educators,
where content, including apps,
books, video, is organized by
subject, by grade, by core
curriculum, just the way
teachers search for it.
It includes tablets that are
priced affordability because
we want to bring that promise
of one-to-one learning into
the classroom.
It includes easy purchasing
options for schools.
So, for example, a teacher
can purchase an app
and try it for free.
They can do bulk purchasing.
They can also use purchase
orders instead of credit cards
since as a school you don't
have credit cards.
And it also includes centralized
distribution of
apps and content directly to
devices with one click.
So what's the opportunity
here for you?
It's in 3D living color,
specifically in distribution,
discovery, and delivery.
So you're an app developer
creating apps for schools
wanting to reach students
and teachers directly.
Google Play for Education will
help you reach that audience
without having to create
a sales force.
You're creating an app.
And you want it to be discovered
by teachers looking
for that particular
piece of content.
The way Google Play for
Education is organized,
teachers can search by subject,
by grade, by core
curriculum component in a
variety of ways to be able to
find your app without having
to go through all the noise
and clutter.
And then finally, if you want
your app to be purchased in
bulk at a classroom level, at
the school level, at the
district level, or even the
state level, you don't have to
do anything.
With Google Play for Education,
we allow teachers
to buy in bulk and also with one
click to provision it to
different devices.
So Google's presence in
education includes
Google Apps for EDU.
We've got 25 million users
worldwide, over 3,000 schools
using Chromebooks, and over
700,000 YouTube videos in EDU.
And what that has done, that
footprint has helped us
establish an ecosystem
of partners in
the educational space.
And those partners, including
educators, came to us and
asked what are we
doing in mobile?
And Google Play for Education
is the answer for them.
It's a natural progression in
Google's educational footprint.
Speaking of teacher feedback,
we've actually been piloting
this in a variety of schools
across the country and got a
lot of feedback from educators
on what they look for in apps.
And I wanted to share
that with you.
So these are some of the things
that you'd want your
app to be strong in.
Educational content is a
no-brainer, especially if it
maps to core curriculum
where appropriate.
Teachers definitely
care about that.
They also want it to be
tablet optimized.
Since we're using Android,
specifically Nexus 7 tablets
for this, you want to make sure
that they have a good
user experience.
It goes without saying, if
you're creating something for
the K-12 market, you need to do
adhere both to regulations
as well as common sense.
So it shouldn't collect
personally identifiable
information.
It should not have offensive
content, et cetera.
And another piece of feedback
that we've been hearing a lot
from across the board is that
teachers and students don't
want to remember multiple
login credentials to get
access to apps.
So we encourage you to use
Google sign-on, so that with
one username and password, they
can access all the great
content on their tablets.
So let's take a look at Google
Play for Education.
So here's the interface with
subjects organized by subject
on the left side.
So let's say I'm a math
teacher teaching
fourth grade math.
And I really want to teach
my students about
prime factors today.
I can select mathematics.
And then, I can also up
here select by grade.
This is fourth grade.
And this gives me all
the different
apps for fourth grade.
And I am looking for something
for factors.
And this is the particular
aspect in the core curriculum
that maps to that.
So with just a couple of clicks,
I've been able to
access all the different apps
that map to what I need to
teach that day.
I can further filter it
by different types.
So I can get other content
like books and videos.
I can search for free or paid.
I can look for which
ones are top rated.
And then, I can also look
at the intended user.
So if I want to instruct today,
if I want it as a
review tool, student
tool, et cetera.
So this particular app
looks interesting.
Let's get more information
on that.
And I see it has a badge for
Q, which means that an
external vendor Q has reviewed
it and found that it is
appropriate for teachers.
And I know that Q is composed
of teachers who
are reviewing apps.
And so as a teacher, I really
can rest assured that this app
corresponds to what
I need to teach.
When I click on Order, I'm
able to select a group of
students that I already have set
up, my fourth grade class,
and enter that group in there.
And with one click, I'm going to
be able to send this app to
all the devices.
I want to also now show you
how you can purchase using
purchase orders.
And for this, I am an Earth
Science chair at the school
looking for an app regarding
the solar system.
Now, I know I had checked this
app earlier through the free
trial and liked it.
It was Q approved,
which was great.
And I want to get it for my
fifth and sixth grade class.
And there's about
150 students.
So I'm going to click--
I'm going to enter 150 there.
And notice how the price
changes dynamically.
And when I click on this, it
actually takes me to a screen
where I can select one of three
POs my school has open
with Google already and use one
of them to pay for this.
So no more having to pay with
my credit card and then
getting reimbursement
for that.
And then finally, I want to show
you how you can search
for all sorts of content
on this.
So I'm a Chemistry
Club president.
And I'm looking for content
on the periodic table.
And I don't know what exactly
I'm looking for, but I know I
want to send some interesting
content out.
I can just search by
periodic table.
And I find not just a list of
great apps, but also books
related to the periodic table
as well as videos.
So I want to check out this
Khan Academy video on the
periodic table.
And I'm able to look at it right
there within Google Play
for Education to determine
whether or not it's something
that I'd want to send
to students.
And it is.
Great.
I'm able to order it.
And again, having set up the
Chemistry Club group at my
school earlier, with one click,
I'm able to send it to
specifically those devices.
So that was a quick view of
Google Play for Education.
I encourage you to go to
developer.android.com/edu,
where there's a lot more details
on what I was talking
about, and also a chance
to sign up to get more
information as it becomes
available.
And together with you guys and
Google, we can actually help
transform K-12 education and
make that vision I was talking
about earlier a reality.
Thank you so much for
your interest.